[Music]
finch is the last man on earth maybe
there's hints of other people out there
but as far as his part of metropolitan
st louis he's the only guy left
but he has the greatest companion in the
world he has
a dog goodyear
i missed you
finch is an engineer and he has built a
robot to help take care of goodyear
his name is jeff hello doug you have a
friend when word of this massive storm
comes on they gotta pile into the family
rv and take off
to the promised land out west
san francisco here we come
it is not human to be alone because in
company we find companionship i believe
in new things we find love you
understand how important this dog is to
me yes the bond between finch and
goodyear
is one that is based on deep affection
and constant understanding
[Music]
who doesn't love a good dog even jeff
loves a good dog
what happened was all the fuss i thought
our communication might improve if i
learned to talk dude
the beautiful thing about the film is
that it's optimistic
hopeful
and it's just delightful come on boys
[Music]
you